decenas de muertes presuntamente
causadas por el calor alertan a las
autoridades de India en los Estados
Norteños de utapradesh y viajar los
directivos de las entidades sanitarias
iniciaron una investigación y
desplegaron planes de emergencia para
evitar más decesos pero Pese a que el
principal llamado a los ciudadanos ha
sido no salir de sus casas muchos
continúan sus labores diarias al aire
libre hace mucho calor desde esta mañana
y la temperatura está alcanzando los 42
a 43 grados centígrados el clima cálido
provoca sudor y la piel se vuelve
pegajosa También tenemos dificultades en
los paseos matutinos antes Veníamos a
las cinco de la mañana y no solía
calentar tanto pero ahora a esa hora
parece que tuviéramos un sol de mediodía
Este martes el Ministerio de salud
reunió a los directivos de su cartera y
dio a conocer el plan de prevención en
el que se incluye el envío de un equipo
con funcionarios de gestión de desastres
y del departamento meteorológico una
orden a los centros de salud para que
den prioridad a los pacientes con
síntomas como fiebre vómito dolor
abdominal o diarrea y para las ucis la
exigencia de tener separadas tres o
cuatro camas para estos pacientes sin
embargo mientras se intenta lidiar con
las fuertes rayos del sol según las
autoridades los peores días Todavía
están por venir algunas partes de utar
pra de hecho experimentarán una ola de
calor cuando las temperaturas aumenten
45 grados por encima de lo normal en los
próximos días
la ONU ha estimado que el segundo
trimestre del año suele ser el más
caluroso en varios países del continente
asiático el organismo también estimó que
los últimos ocho años han sido los más
calurosos en la historia del planeta con
Europa occidental medio oriente Asia
central y el noreste de África como los
principales afectados